okay I've got some exciting news about
the Vsauce soundtrack as many of you
know for the first time ever we are
releasing every single Jake chno song
that vau has ever used all right and
it's going to be on vinyl now Jake and I
have been doing our historical research
and we think we now have a track list
for the complete set there are 90 songs
and they're scrolling by right now but
as it turns out we don't need four
vinyls to fit all the songs we need five
so if you ordered the complete set or if
you're going to order the complete that
you will now be getting not four vinyls
but five and because of this change and
because thousands of people are still
finding out about this every day we've
decided to extend the pre-order deadline
by 1 month so you have until January
22nd these five vinyls they're beautiful
but until you get them just sit back
relax and enjoy the sounds of
sauce